what up space fam golson here from anime
uproar and i have a brand new seven
deadly sense video for you today
this topic is special because it was one
of the first seven deadly sins
topics we ever covered however that was
a few years ago and a lot has changed
since then
so with the manga series being over i
thought it was the perfect time to do a
revamped and updated version of the
video before we get started i want to
give a big thank you to guardian tails
for sponsoring this video
guardian tales is a classic action
adventure rpg with adorable
pixel graphics and i really fell in love
with this game when i first tried it out
it is extremely fun and easy to get into
the controls are smooth and simple and
even the tutorial was fun to play
the game features lots of action awesome
sword
and magic combos more than 50 characters
and
over 200 unique pieces of equipment you
can play single player story mode
multiplayer mode including real time pvp
and four player co-op raids tower and
dungeon mode
and more you can join guilds create your
own floating castle
where you can place buildings and
structures that generate wealth over
time
and you can collect powerful weapons and
beautiful warrior waifus
i love the gameplay the chibi pixel
graphics and the overall
classic feel of the game that brings me
right back to my childhood this game is
honestly a breath of fresh air in the
modern gaming landscape
try it for yourself just click the link
in the description and start playing for
free
right now it's a super fun action-packed
way to pass the time
so check it out link in the description
now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all
first up we have the 750 year old
and 30 feet tall diane our favorite
giant queen
matrona always thought that the ant had
the potential to become the strongest
warrior of the entire giant clan and she
was right
now let's highlight some of her feats
here diane uses a 2
200 pound warhammer as a weapon
illustrating how insanely strong she is
gideon which is the name of her sacred
treasure works in conjunction with her
creation ability allowing her to use it
to its full potential
creation is pretty much earth bending it
capitalizes on the giant clan's
connection to the earth
creation lets her turn solid earth to
quicksand create floating mountains of
earth and drop them down on her
opponents
create giant spikes that jut out of the
earth launch rocks at opponents and so
on so yeah she's pretty much like the
most
opie earthbender you can imagine she can
even create golems from the earth that
can fight for her near the end of the
series she can produce seemingly diamond
based attacks
like diamond tower which should be
significantly more powerful than normal
earthen ones
as queen of the giant clan the ant even
gets strong enough to
help during the fight against the demon
king and when he's in zelda's body
she manages to cut him off from his
supply of magic by creating a new
platform beneath their feet high above
the magic lake
the anne can increase her powers by
using droll's dance and she can also use
heavy metal
an interesting move where as the name
suggests she turns her body into metal
thereby increasing its weight strength
and defense
in one data book that came out before
the series finished the anne's power
level was set to be fifty thousand so
even
if we don't know her exact power level
by the end of the series it should at
the very least be classified as fifty
thousand plus
next let's look at gothard the goat sin
of lust this over three thousand year
old doll has
many abilities under his belt gother is
not just any doll though
he was created by one of the greatest
wizards in history
he was created so well that even the
very talented merlin admitted that she
couldn't improve him
since he's a doll gother is practically
immortal compared to other life forms he
can be rebuilt from the most serious of
wounds that would kill practically
anyone else and he doesn't age
you can cut off his head and he'll just
put it back on gothar has some
superficial doll powers
like being able to change the shape and
color of his hair but his real op
ability is called
invasion which pretty much allows him to
use genjutsu or mind control on his
targets
he can read people's minds and memories
but that's only the beginning he can
also erase and rewrite memories or trap
people inside an illusion
leaving them motionless and defenseless
gother can also enter someone's mind and
communicate with their subconscious but
in this case
his own body would be left motionless
and defenseless he uses his sacred
treasure herot
in conjunction with this ability it's a
magical bow
made out of energy that lets him use his
invasion ability from a much longer
range
he was even able to use his sacred
treasure to render anyone within a three
mile radius who had a spirit level below
400 unconscious another ability revealed
near the end of the series was that
gother has a self-destruction device
inside him merlin made it using magic
extract from escanor sunshine and added
the four elements of destruction to it
and then threw in some of her own magic
infinity to maximize the destructive
power
thus this is an op cocktail made up of
sunshine maximized to infinity
and extra destruction thrown in for good
measure this last resort attack is so
strong that it should be able to
obliterate any and all living things
within a 10 mile radius of gother
gothar's largest recorded power level
was 35
400 after he regained his memories and
in all honesty i did probably expect to
see some further power level upgrades
from gother because pretty much everyone
else got
them but we didn't really get to see
that as a perfectly constructed doll his
power growth might have a certain limit
on it but still the fact that his
self-destruct power is arguably one of
the strongest and deadliest moves in the
seven deadly sins manga means that he
can at least get a tie against almost
everyone in the series
next we got merlin the genius behind the
ultimate self-destruct cocktail
merlin is an alias and her true name
cannot be pronounced by
humans and i know i said it before but
i'm so glad that they turned an
old male wizard from arthurian legend
into a hot 30 year old looking woman
that is artistic license at its best
right there
merlin is the greatest wizard in all of
britannia she defeated the commandment
of pacifism grey road who had a power
level of 39
000 and was especially tricky because of
her commandment if one kills in grey
road's presence
then all of their time is stolen from
them they age rapidly and die ordinarily
people wouldn't be able to kill grey
road because of this
but merlin is able to stop her own time
with the help of her magic power
infinity
thus she could kill in grey road's
presence without anything happening to
her merlin explains her infinity ability
as follows
and i quote no matter how powerful a
magic is all i need to do is invoke it
just once and i can keep flames burning
ice frozen or time stopped for eternity
as long as
i myself do not release the spell end
quote this ability is so appealed that
everyone present during merlin's
explanation can't help but recognize how
unfair it is it's like cheating she then
proceeds to capture grey road and turns
this feared
seemingly unbeatable commandment into
her own personal guinea pig
interestingly enough merlin's highest
power level was 4710 but this is a
pretty useless figure by the end of the
series
not only did she effortlessly turn a
commandment with an almost 40
000 power level into her guinea pig she
also uses her magic to defeat the op
demons chandler and cusack whose power
levels were at least 173 thousand and
168 thousand respectively
but it's not just demons that she
impresses ludochel the archangel prays
to himself that he never makes an enemy
out of merlin not to mention that she
straight up managed to trick both the
demon king and the supreme deity when
she was a child without
ever getting caught by them from the
demon king she got detailed info on all
the secret arts
and mysteries of the underworld and
divine protection that could defend
against the brainwashing of the
goddesses
and from the supreme deity she got
divine protection able to nullify any
and all manner of dark curses and
commandments
she was supposed to choose one gift and
join the leader's side but she just took
both and peaced out her sacred treasure
is a crystal ball called alden
that she uses in conjunction with her
spells among other abilities she can
channel spells through it
see distant locations with it and even
transfer her soul into it if need be
since she's a wizard she has access to a
wide assortment of spells
some of which let her cancel other
spells amplify the magic of her friends
trap opponents within a cube that will
reflect their attacks
back at them teleport create illusions
and much more
merlin can even reactivate the perpetual
reincarnation curse that caused
elizabeth to be reincarnated every time
she regained her memories and died in
addition to being able to let her allies
draw out power beyond their limits
merlin was able to fuse their attacks
into a single ultra powerful attack
and then meliodus increased his power
with a few full counters
and used it to defeat the demon king and
end the holy war
zelda mentioned that this combined
attack would have been able to
completely level
all of britannia then xion did the work
of the supreme deity and the demon king
who worked together in the past to seal
away their creator chaos
for 3 000 years merlin patiently worked
towards this goal and accomplished it
and managed to revive king arthur as the
king of chaos at the same time
it was even her who was behind the
coffin of eternal darkness
that sealed away the demon king and the
supreme deity so i think her
genius and masterminding has to be
included in any discussion of her
abilities
you can question her morals at times but
you definitely can question her genius
next up we have the fairy king himself
king aka harlequin
king goes on to become the most powerful
fairy in history in regards to
superficial abilities he can levitate
and change his appearance
as a fairy he also doesn't age can read
the true thoughts of others
and can't get sick so all in all being a
fairy is a pretty good gig
before we discuss his full-grown wings
power-up let's mention his power called
disaster the ability is explained by
merlin as follows a mere scratch becomes
a grey wound an ordinary poison can
become a fatal toxin
and so on the power allows him as the
fairy king to manage and rule over the
plants and forests by exercising
complete control over life and death
and quote he can even turn a tiny water
droplet extracted from a stick
into a deadly weapon by compressing it
he makes it as strong as an iron ball
and then he can control it
telepathically moving it at insane
speeds
furthermore disaster lets king fully
draw out the potential of his sacred
treasure
chastiful and king arguably relies on
his sacred treasure more than any other
sin does
chastity is made from the sacred tree
and its forms
become stronger as king does in this
video we're going to be looking at some
of its latest op forms
along with his large wings and elvis
hair king also gains the ability to use
multiple chanceful forms at a time
he can produce a powerful barrier that
can easily protect people
within it from miles attacks the new and
improved guardian form
is a giant buff bear with many arms that
can launch a brutal onslaught of punches
strong enough to push around an enemy as
strong as mael
then with his fifth form increase he can
produce countless large swords
and control them effortlessly while
simultaneously
making them all travel at insane speeds
he can also now create a giant true
spirit spear chastiful
that is so large it makes him look like
a bug next to it
definitely big pp energy he can at the
very least use four chassis forms at
once which is pretty crazy he uses these
powers to overpower the suffering mael
who has absorbed four commandments by
this point effortlessly his highest
recorded power level was 41
600 and that was when he still had tiny
wings
but this is terribly outdated since he
could easily beat mile whose power level
was already at
88 000 after one absorbed commandment
let alone after
four next let's look at the one the only
escond his special ability is sunshine
a grace that was originally bestowed
onto the archangel mile
by the supreme deity with it escanor was
at his weakest at midnight
and at as strong as that noon this was
early on in the series but
merlin did say that at his peak escondor
easily surpasses every other sin
escanor's body radiates immense heat in
his daytime form and
as a result anything around him will
turn to ash in this confident and buff
form he can even melt stone
this is where his sacred treasure rita
comes in handy the axe is incredibly
heavy
and unbalanced but escanor can still
carry it effortlessly in his daytime
form the really special thing about rita
is that esquinor can't store all of that
heat and power that radiates from him
inside of it then he can release all
that stored power
at once when he chooses to escondur can
use the stored power
to launch attacks or to turn into his
daytime form at night
interestingly enough escanor can also
call the axe to himself
and it will travel at an incredible
speed from wherever it happens to be
straight to him and then of course we
gotta talk about the one form which
escanor can enter for
only a minute at noon he used this form
which is supposed to be the
manifestation of power itself
to defeat both meliotis and zeldras in
mere moments
he even uses the form to straight up
duke it out with the demon king in
zeldas's body
and he does quite well during that
minute while mentioning how the demon
king's blows are nothing more than an
itch but then the minute runs out and we
think it's over
however that's not what happens eskenore
then enters the one ultimate
by converting his own life force to not
only maintain but to enhance the one's
already incredible power
it comes with a heavy price shaving off
esquinor's own life in the process but
the power lets him punch around the
demon king himself
despite how well he's doing the sins
won't let him go it alone
and they join in eventually finishing
the demon king off together
alas escanor burns through too much of
his life force in the battle and passes
away shortly afterwards but temporarily
he had enough power to push around the
god of demons which is absolutely insane
to think about
escondor's highest recorded power level
was 114
000 which was shortly before noon
however with the one not to mention the
one ultimate we can rest assured that he
far surpassed this power level by the
end of the series
next up let's look at bond the bandit
himself his special ability snatch
is very fitting for a bandit it lets him
rob physical objects or even power from
another person
he's used this ability to steal hearts
from demons but also to steal power
speed and stamina from his opponents
in this way bond becomes stronger better
and faster as the fight progresses while
his opponents become the opposite
however it's not that simple earlier in
the series bond could only absorb so
much power and it was because his body
was not a very fit
vessel this changed when he spent
centuries in purgatory
and came back with one of the most
durable bodies of all time
this was only possible because he was
immortal and his body recovered from the
harsh conditions of purgatory again and
again
until it eventually adapted bond could
always take power
but in purgatory while fighting against
the demon king bond learned how to give
power as well
when bond came out of purgatory he used
this new ability
and gave up his immortality for elaine's
life
so that she could keep on living
alongside him you might think that not
being immortal would make bond weaker
but it's definitely not the case this
series did a good job of showing how you
can be immortal and still be powerless
which we saw when bond couldn't stop
esterosa from killing meliodus but now
after the purgatory upgrade
bond is stronger than ever and his
durability is so high
that he might as well be immortal now
let's take a look at bonn after
purgatory in action
the demon king in meliotis body was
really strong and completely overpowered
the combined forces
of the other sins and the two strongest
archangels albeit king's magic was
drained and escanor was in his weaker
nighttime form
then post-purgatory bond came to the
rescue he was quick enough to save hawk
from the demon king before he could even
react
when the demon king creates an energy
storm that no living creature could
possibly withstand
bond does and even comments how it's an
adorable little breeze compared to
purgatory
he goes on to fight the demon king one
on one and holds his ground long enough
for meliotis to beat him from within and
it's even bond who delivers the final
satisfying punch to the demon king
before he leaves meliodus's body but not
only did bond do that well against the
demon king in meliorus body
when practically no one else could he's
also fine afterwards
and is ready to help fight the demon
king again after he takes over zeldras's
body
it is during this fight that merlin
returns bond's sacred treasure
the holy staff kuretros and he uses it
in conjunction with this ability super
concentration
to destroy countless baby indra a feat
no one else present could accomplish
his highest recorded power level was
actually 3220 which is hilarious because
he went on to become one of the
strongest sins the purgatory boost was
exactly what his epic character needed
and last but not least we got meliotis
our demonic captain himself meliotis
became so strong he had to be nerfed
just to stay in the human realm which is
pretty epic
as we know meliotis was heir to become
the next demon king
and he did unlock powers equal to the
godly demon king
he could have taken on that role but
instead he decided to sacrifice this
godly power in order to destroy the ten
commandments
and by extension his father for good as
a result he's not as strong as he
was but this allowed him to stay in
britannia with elizabeth which is way
more important to him than having godly
power
now let's talk about some of meliotis
specific abilities he's most famous for
full counter which lets him reflect
magic attacks back at his opponent with
double the power
sometimes he likes full countering and
attack multiple times
so that he can make it all the more
powerful before directing it at his
opponent
as mentioned earlier in this video he
can use full counter
to amplify the combined attack of his
allies as well
meliodus can also use demon abilities
like hellblaze
when meliotis used this ability he was
even able to leave a scar
on the immortal bond something that
never happened before
meliotis also has his assault mode and
in this mode he was said to have a power
level of 142 thousand
this is the power he had when he was
meliotis of the ten commandments
esconders the one beat him in this form
but that being said meliotis recovered
much quicker
and took way less damage than eschanor
when he was fighting the demon king to
regain control of his body
he used the move trillion dark to launch
countless spheres of concentrated
darkness at the demon king
and the powerful attack in conjunction
with bond fighting the demon king from
the outside
was enough to defeat him and free
meliotis's body
melionas's sacred treasure lost vain is
a demon-splitting sword that lets him
make the most of full counter
and also to create up to four clones of
himself
although clones are weaker than the
original they can still use full counter
to the fullest
making them very effective against magic
based attacks and although there's
always more to say
i think that does a good job of covering
most of meliodus's powers
he had godlike powers that he had to
sacrifice in order to destroy the demon
king for good
and still has considerable power
remaining suggesting that he was at his
peak significantly stronger than the
demon king himself
who is legit a god in the seven deadly
sins world and keep in mind a much
weaker meliotis could easily
wipe the entire kingdom of danafor off
the face of the earth
so it's safe to say that we barely saw a
fraction of the level of destruction
that demon king meliotis was capable of
if he was a monster in the world of one
punch man he'd definitely be a god level
threat
and that is it for this one if you did
enjoy this video and want to see more
seven deadly sins videos on this channel
then the best thing you can do is smash
that like button and share this video
with any men of culture that you know if
you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future seven daily
sends videos
now that the manga is over i could
revamp a lot of our videos
so if there's a specific video you'd
like to see let me know in the comments
and while you wait for the next video to
drop check out our giant seven daily
sins playlist where you can find videos
about the commandments
about every sin's power level about
every sin's backstory
and much much more link in the
description i also want to thank all of
you because the channel has been growing
faster than
ever and it's unreal we passed 900 000
subscribers and are actually approaching
1 million subscribers and it's all
thanks to you guys
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon who helped
make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself alpha sigma and
are the one-tier patrons the ones who
stand atop all clans stephen andrada
alolan attempt the world acquired
respect but they have a jonathan king
brandon of isles papa smurf emperor
otaku thomas jones kin mano and admiral
and our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh who's the current
most donated
overall champion of the world nothing
but a fan jason wilson
king zeldras anatoly kazatsky angel
crews
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
actor jessica k lefon
hinokami and water bonnie parks rathu
and de ora florion
joanne garcia steelers deadly saint and
stern hawkins thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime pro and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime outbroad link in the description
if you are interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thank you all again so much
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you